richard gere et shark et qu'ils méritent
d'être traitées et il nous reste peu de
temps alors je vous explique de quoi il
retourne c'est une application elle
s'appelle euros fatwa sa page d'accueil
que j'ai regardé vous l'avez été voir
sans doute et plein de conseils
essentiellement alimentaires pour se
comporter en bon musulman en europe
en fait elle est animée cette
application par un personnage interdit
de séjour en france et dans d'autres
pays
un des leaders des frères musulmans il
s'appelle youssef al qaradawi et ce
cheikh qaradawi véhicule au milieu de
préceptes divers des contenus
antisémites violent cette application
est parmi les plus téléchargées en ce
moment sur iphone de quoi faire réagir
la sénatrice centriste nathalie goulet
qui demande tout bonnement
l'interdiction de l'application voici ce
qu'elle dit nathalie goulet elle le dit
dans une tribune au figaro
ça sert à rien en gros enfin je résume
mais vous le voyez ces propos à l'écran
de faire des lois pour interdire les
propos haineux et ça sur internet si
tout ça rentre sur nos smartphones
rien dans le discours ne peut être de ce
fameux cher peut être assimilé à de la
liberté d'expression et c'est de la
haine notamment antisémites
est-ce que effectivement elle a raison
nathalie goulet
parce que l'interdiction se dit c'est
compliqué d'interdire une application
est ce qu'on est ce que c'est faisable
est-ce qu'elle a raison de dire sinon
c'est pas la peine d'aller tenir des
discours très martiaux pour dire qu'on
lutte contre la radicalisation
l'islamisation et autres sujets
polémiques du moment
c'est sans doute pour ça qu'ils ont fait
une application vous souvenez de cette
phrase ici l'on les français parlent aux
français
et bien il y à des organisations qui ont
mis en place une stratégie qu'on connaît
qui s'appelle la taqiyya de
dissimulation diffusent des idées
nauséabondes qui sont des idées
islamistes à travers des actions qui
n'ont rien à voir avec ce qu'elles sont
censées prenez puisqu'elle ne
l'affichent pas ouvertement ça s'appelle
le burqini ça s'appelle ce genre de
choses ça s'appelle les politiques
sociales qui sont dénoncés par robert
parent
gilles kepel dans certaines banlieues
donc sous couvert d'être des mamans à
l'école sous couvert de donner des bons
conseils et bien on essaye de fédérer
des communautés pour disséminer des
idées qui sont clairement ce que
dénonçait macron quand il a dit il ya un
risque que la phrase il ya un islam
politique qui veut faire sécession dans
la république c'est clairement ça et
c'est difficile parce que juridiquement
comment traiter ça et se dire alors
est-ce que ça porte atteinte à la loi de
1881 est ce que ça trouble l'ordre
public
c'est compliqué le temps qu'on ait une
réponse juridique et bien ça ce sera 10
ème âge et d'yves cmh albina vous avez
travaillé sur le sujet vous connaissez
bien sujets possibles alors d'interdire
alors d'un point de vue technique je
juridique déjà sur l'âge selon l'ancien
tueur de cette application font en effet
alors qu'il s'affairait à darwin ne
pratique pas vraiment latakia il a été
très clair non il est pas un il n'est
pas en france mais ses ouvrages vous les
trouvez sans problème en france j'en ai
plusieurs ils sont traduits en français
et il ya aucun lien aucun souci c'est
pas seulement quelqu'un qui est
antisémite c'est quelqu'un aussi qui
prononcent des fatwas qui a du sang sur
les mains qui a fait assassiner des
personnes et qui vous expliquent aussi
très calmement comment battre sa femme
enfin ce il n'y a pas de paca c'est
extrêmement transparent et etc des
séries greg ou comment éduquer également
votre adolescent en effet je pense et
c'est bien sûr tout ça ça commence assez
soft j'allais dire sur la page c'est
tout à fait dans la zone d'application
qui se veut alors il ya le carré les
moyens d'en donner on a tout le
marketing qu'il faut on utilise une
application on sait comment c'est c'est
intelligent c'est extrêmement mal hein
et oui bien sûr qu'il faut l'interdire
maintenant nous croyons quoi pas que
parce qu'on va l'interdire on règle le
problème
en réalité c'est un symptôme mais à une
maladie derrière et vous pouvez
interdire une opinion ça ne la fera pas
disparaître pour autant donc l'interdire
oui et c'est dommage d'ailleurs qui est
une seule députée qui qui se mobilisent
là dessus mais
ne pensez pas que le voilà la maladie
n'existe plus et l'interdiction qui
réglera tout aussi tenté qu'elle soit
possible toujours sur ce sujet alors
effectivement vous le disiez rachel il
ya une actualité sur le burqini sur la
radicalisation islamiste dans les
services publics bruno retailleau
président du groupe l air au sénat
réagissent et ce matin c'était sur ses
news il ya aussi une autre réalité avec
les frérots salafistes d'un islam
politique conquérant qui essaient de
conquérir les esprits des territoires
qui est à l'oeuvre aujourd'hui et fall
nos félins grâce à cet islamisme
d'affirmations il faut réaffirmer ce que
nous sommes nous sommes une république
laïque
les frères aux salles affichent à dire
j'avais jamais entendu cette expression
mais richard briques sur le on en vient
effectivement ou burkini vous connaissez
bien le sport où on a aussi parlé de ce
rapport sur la radicalisation et
notamment par le par le milieu du sport
c'est quoi la solution mais on a on a un
vrai sujet sur le burqini c'est qu' il a
pu être à un moment considéré comme
étant un épiphénomène mais on sait
qu'aujourd'hui ne l'est pas et dire
qu'aujourd'hui il est utilisé dans un
cadre communautariste c'est pas se
voiler la face si je peux reprendre
cette expression
concrètement il faut aujourd'hui
peut-être que des décisions un peu plus
il a été trop mou le maire de grenoble
je ne sais pas s'il a été trop mou je
pense qu'il n'a pas eu forcément la
réponse adaptée c'est ce que je dirai je
pense que d'autres élus
prendront d'autres décisions face à ce
phénomène parce que derrière c'est une
communautarisation qui est en place et
donc très concrètement oui d'autre
réponse que celle du maire de grenoble
devront être prises et je reviens sur le
sujet précédent parce qu'il était
intéressant je parle pas sur le fond
qu'a très bien à développer racing
menace mais sur un autre point
c'est la responsabilisation et la
responsabilité des plateformes
finalement on a cette application qui
est mise en paquets mise en place qui
marche bien on voit que du côté de
google on l'arrête un moment tu en voilà
et donc est du côté d'apple il ya une
quelque chose qui ait une enquête en
fait qui est mise en place en interne
mais elle arrive très tard c'est à dire
qu'en fait on voit qu'aujourd'hui le jeu
c'est d'avoir d'avoir l'appli de faire
de l'argent parce que ça marche dans les
5 jours 55e donc un truc pas en france
mais ailleurs 55e donc c'est plutôt pas
mal
il ya des millions d'applications c'est
pas un petit truc donc on voit bien qu'à
un moment donné le le rapport aussi du
politique avec ses plateformes avec ces
mastodontes
il va falloir qu'il soit retravaillé
autrement ne peut pas laisser une
application à un moment donné comme ça
s'emballe et sans avoir des garde-fous
et sans d'avoir des garanties avant faut
peut-être se poser les questions plus en
amont en tout cas je pense que ça c'est
un nouveau travail qu'on doit avoir avec
les plateformes sinon on va avoir ce
système avait l'air s'est développé à
rendre à l'enzyme et marc landré sur ce
sujet de la possibilité ou non de de
merpins à aulas est assez travaillé en
amont c'est ce qu'ils sont c'est fait
puisque
il faut une plate-forme autorisé ou pas
en amont les à faa'a et diffusé donc a
priori non oui enfin les personnes
perçues personnes sur ce plateau ou
ailleurs dira qu'il faut pas interdire
cette appli si jamais elle elle recèle
effectivement les informations qu'elle
qu'elle divulgue est évidemment en fait
est ce que ça va mais certains parce
qu'on la suite à mais parce qu'on peut
situer plus tôt mais oui me kiffe active
qui avait elle même qui fait la veille
mon souvenir ça une liberté d'expression
totale et dangereuse est maintenant en
allemagne il autorisé à y envoyer un
téléphone pour regarder dedans s'il y
avait des données salafistes apple a dit
non je défends parce que les marques
deviennent politique je défends la
liberté de les utiliser à l'heure d'été
a dit non et bien et alors avant de dire
oui c'est un vrai sujet sauf que ce sont
des plateformes qui sont mondiales et
qu'on soit d'un côté ou de l'autre s'est
retrouvé france et allemagne en 1944 que
c'est une nouvelle fois comme valeur
ledit mortellement dégâts faits à c'est
la solution monde mais j'étais
américains le font peut-être avons-nous
d'ailleurs c'est l'enjeu de des débats
de la primaire démocrate il veut parler
que de ça je pense que c'est un vrai
sujet et bien merci on regarde juste le
résultat de notre quessandier envies
d'ailleurs non apple doit-elle retirer
l'application euros fatwa oui à 81%
judor nous dit non pas interdire c'est
techniquement facile de remonter sur les
connexions sur cette appli
identification fichage enquête lors donc
si je comprends bien c'est une autre
méthode c'est de dire on garde on
regarde la plaie au regarde qu'ici il a
téléchargé on peut ça peut intéresser
des services d' enquête babineau
internet pullulent de contenus haineux
en parlera de federer dont on en a déjà
parlé 7 millions mais pas maintenant
internet pullulent de contenus haineux
le gouvernement a déjà commencé à lutter
interdire une autre application
apparaîtra donc babineau qui si
effectivement
moment c'est de l'être vous vous dites
tous les deux qu'il faut à un moment
dire ça suffit tout les 4 et 4 même si
vous êtes excusés c'était c'était pour
sanctionner votre votre notaire me
dissiper marque aux gens